- [Mark] All right, Pimpsy, Pimpsy,
where'd you grow up, where are you from?
- From San Diego, California.
- [Mark] San Diego.
- Yes sir.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents growing up?
- [Pimpsy] No, actually I didn't,
it was kind of a back and forth thing.
I spent more time with my father
than I did with my mom and,
yeah, I moved out real
early about at 17 years old,
You know what I mean?
I've been on my own since then
and never really turned back.
So you know.
- [Mark] So when you left,
when you left your dad's house,
you went where?
- I got my own place.
Well, actually I had a
friend who had a chic and he,
I don't know why he agreed to it,
but long story short I moved in with her,
we would, that was her part of the spot
and this was my part of the spot,
and I had me some chics
and I got half the spot,
and then he ended up moving her to Vegas
and I took over the whole spot.
You know, it wasn't nothing
major, nothing big and nice
but it was my own, you know,
and I was real young and
happy to have it, you know.
- [Mark] And how did you
get into being a pimp?
At what age did that happen?
- I was playing around at 16.
I started really getting into it at 17,
but I like to say that,
I was straight laced no chase
by the age of about 19,20 man,
you know, because a lot of
times we do a lot of mixing
and doing a thing that the game really
would frown upon at a younger age
but I didn't really have nobody to tell me
or take me by the hand and say, Oh man
these are what you're supposed to do,
It's not what, what
you're not supposed to do.
I mean, I did so many
things now that I look back,
I find it hilarious.
You know, one of the things I used to do
I had a 84 Cadillac old, old bucket.
I think I might've paid
five or $600 for it,
I don't remember
but I had about, I
don't want to exaggerate
but I know I had enough chics
to where I had a car load in the Cadillac
and still I had to go back to my house
and go get another one or two of them,
and I'm pulling up on the stroll
with an old dirty basket bumping,
♪Hey, dirty, baby I got your money, ♪
and it's all types of
real peas out there man.
And I got the windows down
the chics, all out the car
and dancing, and I'm
thinking that these cats
and these real players and
pimps out there is hating on me.
That's my mindset.
They hating on me, man, they mad,
because they see all this
here and they just don't
want to see me shine.
But reality of it was, I
was really making it hot,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm really drawing too much attention,
and you know, it was a
bunch of different things
along those lines, you
know what I'm saying?
I didn't know what to
tell the chic to charge,
my chics out there, charging 20's and $25.
I'm going home with four
chics, four or five chics
with a matter of maybe four or
$500 at the end of the night.
And I'm thinking they mad at me
because my chics is in and out of cars,
but no, they mad because their
chics is charging mine ain't,
so of course they ain't
going to get money.
You know what I'm saying?
So that's basically the
beginning of my game.
- [Mark] So you didn't
have any role models
or anyone to guide you?
- No, not as far as this goes, no.
You know, I didn't, I think
the first role model that I had
that could really tell me
any news that I could use
was Bishop Don Juan and I met
him I believe in probably '04.
So I was about 24, no,
I was younger than that,
because I know we did real
flavor and all that by then.
So I was about 22 when
I met Bishop Don Juan.
- [Mark] You learn from the best.
- Yeah, and he didn't only
just tell me what to do.
You know what I'm saying?
The most valuable information was
was what not to do, what
mistakes not to make.
And that was the most valuable,
you know, cause you know
you can listen to a
person, tell you what to do
and that's the only giving you the game
that they didn't did, you'd
just be copying and repeating.
But the most valuable game I ever learned,
was the game when a person
took the time and tells me,
"Hey man, don't do this man."
"Avoid that speed bump,
watch out for that pothole,"
"you know?"
And, and that's what gave me
such a longevity in the game.
I mean, you know, I did that
from that age all up to 33
and I didn't ever, I
never did nothing else
in between the time, back
then, you know what I'm saying?
It wasn't, no, it wasn't no game plan.
It wasn't no, selling
drugs or selling dope,
it wasn't nothing like that.
Every dollar I had smelled
like pussy up and from,
from the time of 19, all the way up to 30,
like I said before that 18, 17,
I was mixing and doing all
type of other stuff too.
- [Mark] So how many girls
did you have in your staple?
- Did I then?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Oh man.
I didn't, I know I didn't came to the ball
with probably four or five at sometime,
and I leave the other ones at home.
I mean, I didn't have quite a few man,
I didn't have quite a few, you know
and these things I can say
because it's all documented.
I don't have to like, I ain't
got to hide that from you all.
- [Mark] And so yes, you did
some prison time recently?
- Yes, yes, yes.
Very much so, federal prison time.
- [Mark] Seven years for what?
- It was actually a RICO charge,
and then I,
it was really because I went
to trial and I went to trial,
I fought the federal government
and they tried to give me 23 years
and I just went to trial on it.
There's inside the case
there's all types of things.
You've got young cats pimping on minors
and so forth and so on,
and when you're dealing with a RICO case,
everybody gets charged
with the same crimes,
and that was part of my issue with it.
I didn't want to be put into that same bag
with a bunch of guys that
made the wrong decisions
and rather than take this plea deal
where I would have went straight home.
I'd rather fight it and, you know
see what comes to me and take my chances.
- [Mark] So the seven years
were for pimping and pandering?
- RICO,
RICO, racketeering enterprise
that's the main charge.
- [Mark] Oh, I see, okay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So when you had
things going smoothly
before the government got involved,
the arrangement with the girls
is that you keep how much of their money
(Pimpsy chuckles)
- How much can they get?
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] And the girls are what races?
- You name it.
I prefer not to have black
chics, you know what I'm saying?
I started off that way,
so I got a good dose of
exactly the strain on the game
that they can give you,
if they allow you to,
but being a black man myself,
going to school with them
and being around the neighborhood
you be real familiar with them,
and those are most likely
going to be your first chics,
you know what I'm saying?
And so that's where it
started off with but,
when I got my first piece of
snow man, I was turned out.
I was trying to, the
money, the money difference
was just too much of a
comparison to even think about,
and so I kind of focused
my way there, but--
- [Mark] What's the
problem with black girls?
- Well,
- [Mark] Headstrong?
- You could say that,
you can say that word,
I'm going to say this man,
and their money don't
match their problems,
you know what I'm saying?
The perks don't match their problems
and that'd be the problem,
you know what I mean?
If I could, you can give me
all the problems you want
if I'm making a million dollars
out of you, I don't mind
but I'm not going to deal
with so many problems
for a hundred dollars,
you know what I mean?
I'm not going to do it, you know
and then it was just too
much for me, you know?
And then to be honest,
it evolved more into,
I'm really deep into my culture as well,
and I really didn't want to
feel like I was bringing more
onto my people than they already
done went through you know?
And this is just an awakening
that I had at some point
you know, in the game as well,
and that's a whole nother subject that,
might want to go into some other time,
but it all just made more sense to me
because that's what liked
me, you know what I mean?
I like what like me too, you know?
And for the most part, you know
white chics kind of dig
me, you know what I mean?
And I kind of dig them.
- [Mark] So, as a pimp,
you provide security,
you're a money manager.
Tell me what, what
you're doing on your end.
- Be easier to tell you what I don't do.
- [Mark] Okay.
- You know what I'm saying?
only thing I can't provide
for them is arrest haven.
Other than that, I mean, you
name it, I mean, that's my job.
You know what I mean?
Because they gave me their all,
they give me a hundred percent,
you know why I went to chics they will,
"can I give you half my money?"
I'll say, "I'm going to give
you half my pimping then,"
you know?
And when you get down
to thinking about it,
they not with that, you
know what I'm saying?
They're going to want a
hundred percent of you,
and that's why I need a hundred percent.
So that entails when they need comfort,
when they need somebody to talk to,
when they need a tampon sometimes,
they might, you know what I mean?
You're going to have to go do it.
You know what I mean?
If that's really your
chic like that, I mean
first year growing, I
might've had a problem with it
in my mindset, but I got
past that real quick.
You know what I mean?
What you need?
I'll go get it, if you. know what I mean,
if you're busy or something going on,
so there's nothing I won't do, you know,
it's almost the whole Bonnie
and Clyde syndrome thing,
you know what I'm saying?
Where it's, you know, it's
me and you against the world
and you know, it's whatever
and you also gotta realize
these cats these days
these youngsters, man,
it ain't really so much
how it was back then,
because back then yo chic
risked her life for you
every night, every night,
you know what I'm saying?
It wasn't no internet where
they could be tracked,
and the phone now that could be found,
a camera that the hotel
might see the guy come in,
no man, you're chic
getting in and out of car
at random spots going to random places,
and if you, I started when
it wasn't really everybody
having no cell phones.
So the chic going to have to
go to a payphone and call you.
You might not even have no phone yourself.
You want have to just ride
up and down the stroll
until you see her back down.
You know what I'm saying?
So during those times, yes
a chic going to pay you
for security and all that,
nowadays, man, a chic just paying you
because she wants somebody to,
share her lifestyle with,
pretty much, you know?
- [Mark] It's almost like a
romantic relationship, right?
I mean, that's what I, I see
it evolve into a lot, man.
It's really hard to find people that,
find players and pimps
man, that's really, really
sticking to it, based on
the principles of the game.
You know what I mean?
They playing on them, they
playing on these chics mindsets
and playing boyfriend and stuff.
And that's why you see when
these internet sites shut down
they left a lot of prostitutes
with nothing to do,
they don't know where to go or what to do,
and his dude, they sit in there stumbling,
twiddling their thumb and
they don't know what to do.
It was easy to just go post the chic
and wait for the phone to ring.
But you know, that can't happen no more.
Now they got to think outside the box,
they got to figure out man, okay,
she here, she ready to get it
but what am I going to do with her?
where am I going to send her
to, you know what I mean?
And now it's all the old veterans
and all the guys that
started from way back, see,
it's easy for them because
they didn't have all this
even if they was using the computer.
These days that was just something
that was taken advantage of
but their knowledge was set to where,
you know, I could take this chic
and put her in front
of a porn video store.
She going to get money there,
or I could take her to this hotel
because it's going to be a big
convention this week in town.
And she could walk
around downtown and make,
you know what I'm saying?
And they going to think outside the box
because of what's going on in the area.
But see they not doing that now
all they knew before was post the chic,
wait for the phone to
ring, you know what I mean?
And then worse than that, half the chics
ain't going to do nothing,
if the phone ain't ringing
they not going to go, that's
too much work for them.
It was easy to sit at
the room and watch TV
and play on the internet
until a date came.
But you think using their
brain to figure it out
and thinking, no, they not with that, man.
They not with that.
- [Mark] Do you have sex with girls.
I have, I have, not all of
them, you know what I mean?
Because with me, it was a matter of
I have to feel a certain way,
and when I say I have
to feel a certain way,
I have to feel that she's really for me
because in me I get back then,
you'll get a lot of chics, You'll know,
you will feel like I I might have,
I might get a week or
two run out of this one.
I might get a month run out of this one.
You know what I mean?
She did came from five or six other cats.
So I know I might get two or three more,
I'm not nailing her, I
ain't got nothing for her.
But if I know, it's a chic
that is really really for me
and I could see her heart
that all she wants to do is make me happy,
well that turns me on, I can't lie to you.
You know what I mean?
It's a real turn on to me to know that,
you know what I mean?
That she's there from, you know
I come from a background of not,
I ain't got much family,
I don't have a lot of people
that I could have turned to
and stuff like that growing
up, so with that being said,
my females became my family,
my females became, you know,
the first thing I knew about
what love even resembles,
you know what I mean?
It was them.
So that's when I would feel
a sexual attachment to them.
But without the dedication,
I don't feel it.
And being, you know, the type
of pimp that I have been,
you'll give females that
just want to come with you
because of your name, they
want to be seen with you.
They want to be known because
they with you or whatever.
And after the glitter
and the grime wears off
and they realize, Oh, I'm
still doing, I'm still working,
I'm working even harder.
You know what I'm saying?
I got it, you know what I mean?
They don't be worth the status,
it ain't worth the work to them.
So them type of chase, nah
I'm not going to let them get
a piece of me and run off.
But as far as just having sex with them
there have been quite a few
that I've been, you know
that I felt that way towards,
you know what I mean?
And it's not something that you do every,
I do every night or every day.
But if I feel that way towards
the chic, yeah, I might
that's going to be one I know I can,
I might have five of them.
And out of that five,
two or three of them,
I might actually deal with like that,
but the other two, you
know, I already know,
they just here for the meantime,
they going to go to
another pimp, another pimp,
and you've always got to
remember, whatever happened,
they're going to run that to
them, you know what I'm saying?
Me, I don't want to hear
about your other pimp,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm going to be able
to figure out about him
by what you do, by what the chic does,
how she interacts, I don't
need to even hear about him
but these other dudes, a lot
of times they gonna want to
hear about me.
"Oh, what was he like, what was he doing?"
So my reputation going to spread
through her and I gotta be,
I have to be thoughtful of
that when I deal with a chic,
because she going to go somewhere else,
I've got to make sure that
whatever I do with her,
I'm not going to be
ashamed of her telling,
you know what I'm saying?
or speaking on.
- [Mark] The reputation or the stereotype
that pimps had or have is that
they intimidate or they force
the girls into doing things,
but it's actually much more
- I mean, you got some,
that's the gorilla pimp,
you know what I'm saying?
Mentality, you know what I mean?
But my prosecutor on my case,
she even spoke on it and said,
"No, he's a finesse pimp,
you know what I mean?"
Because of course a jury
wants to understand, you know
they don't understand how,
there's no victim saying, Oh
Pimpsy did this to me or did that to me,
so she had to explain it to him,
you know, he doesn't
force him to do anything,
you know, he, my thing is this.
If a chic don't want to be with me
or do what I need her to do,
then I don't want her around
because I believe inside of
me that when I talk to her
and I give her this game, then
that's what she going want.
It ain't gonna be no way around
it. You know what I mean?
She's going to want to
do that, and if not,
it ain't going to last long, no way.
Now I get runs, and
what a run is basically
when I get a chic, I don't
have her most of the time
for no couple of months.
Most of the chics I've had in my life,
I've had for years and years and years.
You see what I'm saying?
So when you're dealing in that
it's just a whole different
ball game, you know?
And when you gorilla pimping on the chic,
a lot of time it ain't going to last long,
because at some point it's not her family,
her mama or whatever, somebody's
going to get in her ear,
and you know, another
pimp going let her know
and he ain't going to do
that to her or whatever
and she might just run off
as far as chastising him.
I know dudes that have
physically chastised the chic
and they not considered gorilla pimp,
they just discipline
them, see what I'm saying?
So it's a different.
Now if you get dudes, that's
pulling up on the whole stroll
and throwing the chic in the
car and telling the chic,
yeah, she got to work, that's
the gorilla pimp mentality.
And to me, man, that's just too much work.
If I could imagine, I
could never do that shit.
It sounds like too much work.
- [Mark] What's the personality trait
that helps you the most to succeed at this
- Honesty. I mean, as far as I go, I mean
it's the whole honesty factor.
Whether it sounds good or not,
when a woman hears it,
she's going to believe
it's more honesty to come
and they feel comfortable with honesty.
You know what I mean?
A chic might come to me and tell me,
"well, I want to, I want to
work, I want to do this for you"
"but I'm doing it because
I want to be your girl"
and I don't do this, and I tell her like,
"No, it ain't going to be that,"
"this is how it's going to work,"
You know what I'm saying?
She might not agree with that,
you know what I'm saying?
But I'm going to give her some incentives
that to take the place of that,
and we are going to have
to work out an agreement
because I'm not going
to sit here and tell you
that I'm a dude, be this
guy, be that guy for you
if I'm not, because you're
going to still expect that.
You know, like I said
you're putting your life on
the line for me every day.
So she's going to have those
expectations in the end.
So I think that the
honesty that I give them
whether it be the hard truth or not
is really what they appreciate.
I got chics that I dealt with.
Like I say, from those
years when I was 18, 19, 17
they called me through my whole biz,
send me pictures through my whole biz.
You know what I mean?
And all they tell me is all
these years later is, you know
I've never met anybody like you
and everybody I've met since you was just,
and I think it's because of
the honesty that I gave them
and I just I always was clear
with them from the gate.
I'm not good at remembering
a lie, you know?
And I, I tell my son about, you know
all these rappers talking
about boss this and boss that
and I say, man, a boss
ain't gonna lie to nobody.
When you lie to somebody as a boss,
that means they your boss now.
You're a boss and you lying to somebody,
you are not, that person
becomes your boss,
because I ain't never,
I don't see no reason why a boss
should have to lie to a subordinate.
And I take that mentality with me.
So if I even caught myself
attempting to lie to a chic,
I just feel like I made
her, my boss and I can't,
I don't, I, that won't work well with me.
You know, I'd rather
tell the truth and to her
and walk away and see what happens.
And I'm gonna be honest with you, man
eight times out of 10, they're
going to appreciate it,
and they going to come around.
- [Mark] Do you ever have
girls that are doing more
than just having sex for money?
They're kind of figuring
out who's got money
and trying to figure out
ways on how to get it?
- I mean, at first I
wasn't with that, you know
but when you start hitting the
other States there's Miami,
there's Memphis,
Tennessee, and Chicago, man
you learn about the chics that know
how to slip a Rolex and crack them a safe.
And you know, I remember,
you know, being with a bunch
of peas on the whole stroll or something,
somewhere in Miami or something, Oh man,
what'd you get tonight, man?
I'm popping man,
yeah man I got about $2,000, man.
Yeah, a chic really been
around here getting it, man.
And you know what I'm saying?
I'm thinking I'm popping.
He tells me, yeah. Yeah.
Well, my chic made about 35,000 a night.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like, huh, you know what I mean?
I didn't really get it until
they broke it down to me.
You know what I'm saying?
They can go get a piece
of jewelry or something
and then go get the money for it,
and that chic ain't even looking,
she ain't even looking
to have sex for real,
I mean, if it's like that and
that's all that's going on
that's what she will do,
but that's not her first
initiative with them dudes,
them chics is trying to make
a hundred thousand that week.
You know what I mean?
And I picked up on it,
but I never really school
chics on that, the chic had
that mindset and that skillset.
Okay, well, okay.
You know, I nurture it,
but at the same time
you also don't want to put
a chic in that situation
that ain't built like that.
And then she get in trouble or something
and then she get caught
and now she feels like you to reason
and now she want to bring you in on it,
you know what I'm saying?
but if that's the chic mentality,
that's her thought process, well I mean,
she going to do it either
way or you know what I mean?
All you can do is make
sure she do it right.
So yeah, you definitely, I
definitely evolve into some
of that as well, but I
wasn't fortunate enough
to have as many as my chics
like that as my friend had
because like I said, a lot of time
them was the black chics that
was, you know, fast like that,
so, you know, me having
white girls and different races,
a lot of times they'd be
a little more apprehensive
let's say about those types of situations,
and I was okay with that, you know.
- [Mark] You have how many kids?
- I have two boys.
I don't have any kids, two grown men.
- [Mark] Two grown men.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And how would you feel
about one of them
following dad's footsteps?
(Pimpsy chuckles)
- It's funny because me and my
son had a conversation often,
as a child, I tried to hide it from him
You know, I tried to tell him
that I was in the music industry
and all the women he would see around me
was girls from the videos
and, you know, I came
with all types of drag.
But the thing about it is
that these are the
females that raised him.
You know, I spent a lot of time doing that
and I got incarcerated when they were
around the ages of 13 and 12 and 13.
So, you know, the internet is there,
they can look and they can figure out
you know what I'm saying,
what their old man is up to.
And I believe they might've
known a little bit prior to that
but I would still denying,
you know what I mean?
And they wouldn't just come out and say,
"Well this is what you're doing dad."
Or but they would ask, you know, like,
"What does she do?"
You know, now the internet age was,
they can go on Instagram and
see one of the chics that I got
with her titties half out,
you know what I'm saying?
or some sort of,
it was getting kind of harder
to even keep up that facade.
So long story short, I did
a lot of trying to hide it.
And now that they're of age,
I really, I prefer that they,
that they find something
that they really truly love
because the way I pimp, it was way harder,
you know what I'm saying?
The way I did it, you know
it was a lot of times where I
might meet a chic at a club,
you know what I mean, a model chic.
I lived on South Beach for a
while and I meet model chics,
and I'm talking about
really beautiful women
from other countries.
And we, might be back of the house,
I might be there had all kinds of drinks.
I'm talking about three or four
and they kissing and
playing on each other,
but I know I can't have sex with them
because if I do in my mind
it brings my value down
and then bringing my value down.
It's going to make it
harder for me to knock chics
and get more females
because I don't have the
I was never the outgoing pimp
to walk up to every female
he sees, Oh man, what's
going on with your baby?
I never did that.
I built up my reputation
in the hopes that a female would find me.
You see what I'm saying?
And the only way you're
going to do that is
by showing a sense of exclusivity
is what I like to call it.
You know, the more exclusive I am,
the more they want me, you know?
And then when chics is
going back, telling them
girl I spent the whole night at his house
and I slept in the bed
and he wouldn't touch me.
You know what I mean?
That the girl she's telling,
going to be like, "For real?"
and it's going to make them wonder,
it's gonna open up that curiosity.
So if the girl I did that
with don't want to pay me
or give me nothing, the chic
she telling might be like,
"well that's the type of guy I want."
You know what I'm saying?
Because especially a prostitute
because a prostitute don't
want to be out working
and getting your money just
to find out you over here,
spending all day with this free girl
having sex with her and
spending money on her.
That's a turnoff to her.
When she know her dude
didn't have sex with her
to begin with, when he first
met her till he got paid,
then she knows that in her
mind, she can go to work
with a clear head knowing
that's not what he's doing now.
You know what I mean?
Her whole focus is my
duty as a businessman
and whatever he was doing is for us,
anything any movement he make
is going to benefit us as a whole
the way I grew up pimping,
I didn't get to do a lot of
things that I wanted to do.
You know, I had to deprive
myself of quite a few things.
I mean, I didn't, in
my first ménage à trois
till I was 30 years old,
you know what I'm saying?
I was ducking that, I
was really ducking that,
you know what I mean?
I wasn't having sex unless
than a female paid me.
You know what I'm saying?
Up front, you know what I mean?
It wasn't no, you know, just
meet, old Sally down here
and I'm giving it to her
at the end of the night
hoping that she decides
to give me money later.
I wasn't doing none of that.
And, but that's something that, of course
every man wants to do, and
I want that for my kids.
You know what I'm saying?
I want my kids to be able to
say, yeah I just met this chic,
I think she was attractive.
And you know, I like her,
you know what I'm saying?
I want to, you know, go spend now.
I want them to think
that way and go do it.
Why? Because they got whatever
business they got going on
or whatever lifestyle that they living
is producing their finances
and they're not having to do
they're not having to judge.
They find time, entertainment time
based on how they make
their money, you know?
But at the end of the day
at that, anything that they
decide to do, I'm going to
do my best, support them
and be there for them.
Because I know how it's like
to not have to not have that.
You know what I mean?
But my thing is to try to
steer them into a direction
that's going to be something
that they really feel
and they enjoy and that's in their heart.
You know what I mean?
And to do, because this right here,
this ain't something that's hereditary,
this is something that that's instilled
individual by individual.
It don't matter if you're,
if your dad was a pimp
is something a matter of,
if you got it in your heart
it's going to be in you,
regardless of who you was raised by
who you grew up around,
it's going to be something
that was in you from birth.
And my mind said, I believe that.
- [Mark] Were drugs ever
a part of your scene?
- As part of me?
- [Mark] You or the girls?
I don't do drugs.
I used to smoke weed, a lot of weed
at one point in my life, sip
Promethazine and Codeine,
You know, I was real tight
at one point with the rapper,
Pimp C, black people know about
that whole, whole situation.
And with his passing it kind of
changed my whole thinking around it.
It was something that he was
really dedicated to, you know
both of us stop doing.
So, you know, after that,
I kind of left that alone.
But other than that
I just smoke weed and drink the champagne.
You know, I, it would be hard for me
to do drugs when I don't allow my chics to
you know what I'm saying?
So they gonna be curious
and they gonna want to know
that they might not do it around me
but they'll go out
somewhere and experiment.
If they started what I did, you know
- [Mark] So your girls are not into it.
- No, I don't even really,
I would prefer them not
to even smoke cigarettes.
You know what I'm saying?
So drugs is a no-no, you know
because who going to get the
money first, if she got a habit
it's going to go to the dope man,
I've got to wait for him to get
his issue before I get mine.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't with that.
You know,
I ain't going to say I've
never had a female that did
but I didn't know about it.
You know, I went through
a phase in my life
where I didn't even know what
crystal meth was, you know?
And that's a drug where a
female is still be beautiful.
I'm talking about real beautiful.
And she going to go be
able to work for 14 hours,
20 hours straight.
So you think you just got
to a, a cold chic man,
this, she just so much about my money,
all she care about is getting my money
but really she is that
hyped up on the stuff
to where, she don't even
realize the time of day,
the time of night, all she
know is she want to keep going,
keep active and she just
keeps getting money.
And I didn't know, I
didn't know the difference.
I didn't know what it was.
I'm looking for chics on crack, you know
those types of drugs, so
I didn't know about that.
So when I would find out or
when I would learn about it
and I would do my best to
try to get them some help.
As a matter of fact,
there's a chic I dealt with
and shen she was on this
show, she's on Netflix,
it's called Addicted.
She's a chic that I had at one point
and I had to sit down and talk to her
when my other chic told me what she does.
And I let her know, I'm like, look, man,
you know, you should, you know
go get yourself straight and
you can do everything right,
you can always come back,
you know what I mean?
I sent her home to go, you know
on the plane and go get it right,
and she didn't immediately go do it
but one of my partners
called me one day and said,
"Hey man, your chic on this
show, go look at her on Netflix"
And there she was, you know what I mean?
And she was blowing big
clouds of smoke, crystal smoke
at one scene and by the end
of the show, she was in rehab,
And you know, at the end I
guess it was a month later
and she was doing good.
You know, she never did come
back but the case in fact
is that, you know, she
went and got herself right,
and I've never been the type
to want to just have a chic
on drugs and the money
wasn't that serious to me,
because I've always been
confident that I'm going
to get another chic, you know what I mean?
I, my game, the way I put it down,
I can do better and she can do better.
So there's no point of us doing that.
- [Mark] So the laws
have changed quite a bit
over the years since you started right?
- You know, when I got
arrested, see, I didn't,
I played the game to where
I could never be arrested
but for pimping, you know what I'm saying?
And that's the way the law is set up,
that's not really no big charge, man.
You might do two or
three years would have.
As long as you got a woman of age
and all you're doing is
pimping, you ain't forcing her,
you ain't, you know,
whooping her to death,
you ain't really looking at
no time and that's my mental,
and that was my mindset.
So I was ready for that, if that ever came
but there was no need
for that to ever happen.
So that's how I thought it was, man,
I thought it wouldn't be no problem.
Well, now they got this law
called the RICO, you know
and they can get you for
just being associated
with a group of guys that may be pimps,
a group of guys that may be drug dealers,
a group of guys that may be gang members
and being with that group
is all it takes to catch
this charge, you see?
And that's something that a
lot of these cats don't know,
man, and they don't really exploit that
as much as they should.
So they'll see me
getting arrested and say,
"Aw, man he just, he did that
wrong, he did this wrong."
No, you ain't gotta do nothing wrong.
All you gotta do is be
around some other pimps,
and you don't know what
they do when they go home
or what they doing with
this chic or that chic
but you hanging out with them,
you thinking in your mind,
well, I don't do what he do.
I ain't got going on what he got going on
but that doesn't matter to them.
All that matters is you
associated, you know
and that's going to be your downfall.
That's, what's going, that's
what's going to get you,
you know?
So if you, if you're not ready for that
if you're not prepared for that, man.
You know, this is something
that you don't even
need to be involved in.
You, need to find you a job
in a lawyers office or McDonald's,
you know what I'm saying?
So that's one of the main things that I,
my missions that I'm
making my life right now
is to kind of make these young cats aware
what they getting into
because you're not just
going to get into this
thinking in your mind, I'm
just going to make some money
out of some chics, I'm going to get rich.
Now there's pitfalls
that can come your way.
and I'm a perfect example of
that, you know what I mean?
This could happen to me, it
could happen to anybody because
in my mindset, I don't break no law,
I don't deal with no minors,
I don't, I ain't beating up on them,
I ain't force no chics to do nothing.
I sat back and looked
at all the other cats
who was doing that and
be the first one to say,
Oh yeah, he messing up,
he going to be in trouble,
it's going to happen
to him, he going to be,
but it happened to me,
you know what I mean?
They're going to
constantly make these law.
They call it human trafficking now.
That term used to mean
coming from one country
and you bring them out
to this country, it
don't mean that no more.
It means coming from the
club to the computer,
you know what I'm saying?
You just human trafficked her
you ain't even took her a block.
You know what I'm saying?
So that's just really
one of the main things
that I really got to focus on.
You know, now I focus myself
on trying to find ways
to evolve, you know,
and take what I've been and how I've been,
the person that I have been
to evolve to where, you know
they don't have no reason
to come mess with me.
When they look at me,
they may say, yeah, well
this is what he was doing,
this what he had going on,
but when they go down
the whole list of thing
they don't have no reason
to come lock me up no more.
And I want to make sure
that everybody else
that's coming up in this game,
like I did man, avoid that.
This is the potholes and dips
in the road and bumps in road
that I was talking about earlier.
This is my way to give back.
You know, like I said, Bishop Don Juan
gave me the potholes
and pitfalls to avoid.
But during his time, it wasn't an issue.
In his time, you know, they
just came from the mafia area
when they was getting the RICO charges.
That's what it is, it's a mafia charge.
So basically that's
what was going on then.
It was no need to tell
young pimps about that
because it wasn't going on.
But now it's my generation and this is the
this is the game that I
need to get in, you know?
And that's really why
I like to still be out
and talking to these young cats, man,
I got to let them know, man,
that you know, it ain't all peaches, man.
You gotta be able to move smooth
and you gotta move correct,
and you gotta really
think about your game,
and you gotta make sure it's
what you really want to do
and the risks that you want to take,
because this is what could happen.
I almost did seven years behind this man
and I missed a lot of time on my kids,
my kids grew up on me,
you know, my mom, she ate,
I missed my best friend in the world
and I missed having my partners,
you know what I'm saying?
Some of my best friends,
you know, my family,
Don Juan, little Mac, little Annie
and all them man and all
my people in Chicago.
And, you know, from state to
state, these are my family.
They ain't just my pimp partners,
they're just dudes that I done.
You know, these is my family and friends
that I put my life on the line for
and you gonna miss out on time with them.
So you gotta make sure
that you ready for that
and that you prepared to do that.
You know what I mean?
Because the last thing you
want to do is get there
and they give you these
paperwork and tell you,
"Hey man you want to go tell on so-and-so"
because whatever reputation you did build,
all of them years is
over with, is over with.
- [Mark] Which of the
girls that you've had
working for you has been your favorite.
(Pimpsy chuckles)
- Oh man see, you're
going to get me in trouble
with that one.
- [Mark] Well I guess yeah.
- I'm not gonna say no
names but I had a real,
real good chic man.
And this is years and years back,
the young lady had a twin
sister and she was so down.
She brought her twin sister around
and having twin sisters at a time
when a whole stroll was popping man,
you can't imagine how amazing
that was from my reputation,
you know what I mean?
To have twins walking, twin models
walking up and down the whole
stroll and really down for it
and really, really about
getting my check man,
and that was, you know,
she knows who she is
but she doesn't know how I feel about her.
You know, she knows that
I was real fond of her.
And so yeah, I had her
and I've had quite a few
others that to this day,
I'm still in contact with
I'm actually I'm contacting
maybe 90 or 85% of them,
even just as friends.
You know what I mean?
We just, we know we just friends,
a lot of them are older now,
they might be in the church.
They might have kids, they
have regular jobs, families,
husbands and all types of stuff,
but you know, they
gonna always check on me
and make sure I'm all right,
and if they need a thing from me,
they can always get it from me.
So, you know, like I
said, being an honest,
being an honest pimp and you know
always sticking out to
my end of the bargain
and doing what I'm supposed
to do, makes it to where
it's kind of hard to choose
who my favorite would have been
because I've had so many good ones.
Like I said, I get run five
years, seven years, eight years.
So it's kind of a toss up.
It's about a tie between
about three or four of them
just honestly, you know?
- [Mark] Good answer.
- Yeah.
That's the basic point
of it, man, you know
but I had to give the first one her
because she really put
herself out there for me.
I mean, one time I was on the stroll
and I was with a a good
pen friend of mine man,
and some dudes tried to Rob
me and tried to jump out on me
and beat me with bats and
all types of stuff man.
And she came from where she
was working at down the street
and she fought them off
when nobody else was able
to do anything, you know
and it, and this is the
same chic I'm talking about.
So it didn't just go
from her getting money.
It went her getting money
to her, putting her,
her life was unimportant in
her own mind compared to mine.
And the stories could
just go on and on and on
with her and several other chics, man,
some of this chics do amazing things
that'll bring a tear to your eyes
if you just really was there to see it
it really like you know what
I mean, if it was a movie,
you know, parts of the movie
come and you see the sad parts
it ain't really gotta be that sad.
It might just be beautiful,
and it might bring a tear out of you.
These are the type of things
that happen in this game,
You know what I mean?
A lot of us don't get
addicted to the money.
We get addicted to the love
and what's going on in it.
You know what I'm saying?
You want to get a new chic
because you want to feel
that love one more time.
You want to feel that comradery
with that chic again, man
you know, and it don't even
gotta be about the money
all the time, it's just
the fact that you know
what she'll do for you,
you know what I'm saying?
And it's just so tough to
explain that to these young cats,
man because they don't have
that opportunity no more.
All they can have as
a female to tell them,
"Oh, I would die for you"
when we had chics that
actually took that chance
and proved that they would, you know,
and that's a foregone time
but I was blessed enough
to be during that time,
to be able to feel that love and that,
and that pushed me on and motivated me
to try to be the best I could be
and try to evolve into whatever
I could possibly become.
- [Mark] What qualities
did you look for in a girl?
- Well, off the top, dedication
and once again the same
probably look for me.
I want it to be honest,
you know what I mean?
I wanna let them know, man, you know
regardless of what
happened, don't lie to me
because a lie that's gonna make it
to where I'm always going
to think about you lying
and that's going to draw
a distance between us.
You know, even if it's
embarrassing or it may hurt you,
man, just tell the truth,
you know what I'm saying?
So dedication, honesty.
I mean, you prefer them
definitely look nice.
But as most of us know,
it ain't in the beauty,
it's in the duty, you
know what I'm saying?
So those are the main things you want.
I mean, I may get visually
blinded by her appearance
if her conduct is a hundred percent
I don't care how she look,
you know what I'm saying?
So, you know
that's going to be the main
thing you want to get around.
You want to meet her, You
want to see how she dedicated,
she asking you questions, you know,
"what do I do if this happened?"
"what do I do if that,"
she's really trying to
figure out what to do
to make this work between you and her.
You know what I'm saying?
Those are the things you want,
you don't want to just to chic
that her main motive is something else,
and she just there to try to
reach that motive, you know?
And you can tell that and
it's not going to last long.
So my main thing is I like the dedication
and the comradery, you know, and honesty.
- [Mark] All right,
Pimpsy, thank you so much.
- Man thank you.
- [Mark] It was a great talk.
- Yes it was.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Church y'all.